At this point,
we could perhaps make updates to our model that increase its accuracy.
Its accuracy is quite high at this point.
And it would probably be more fruitful to consider new questions all
together that our analysis has opened up.
For example, how well is this model generalized to other users of Twitter?
Can we classify Twitter users into different classes distinguished by
which type of model characterizes their tweeting habits.
We've made a model that predicts time to next tweet overall, but
can we now build a predictor for time to tweet about a specific subject.
As you can see,
our analysis is opened up the room to many possible new investigations.